greetings gals and ghouls I am Walter
Venezia and welcome to October top 5
today we're taking a look at something
truly scary the worst of a Canadian
children's television show last week we
delved into the best goosebumps had to
offer however what it had to offer
wasn't always good while this show holds
a special spot in the haunted hearts of
the kids who grew up watching it
goosebumps had some really bad stinkers
across its 74 episode run but what are
the worst spooky tales feature in the
series which ones left us with a feeling
not a fear but a disappointment
these are the top 5 worst episodes of
goosebumps number 5 return of the mummy
from season 1 we have an Uncle Ben in
this episode it was destined for failure
Gabe is visiting his Uncle Ben and
cousin Siri as they excavate an ancient
Egyptian tomb Gabe gets lost while
searching around and eventually stumbles
upon the entrance to where the mummified
Egyptian Prince lays through the magic
of a summoner he bought at the airport
and involvement of a reporter who isn't
who she seems the mummy is brought back
as an undead monster Gabe us now stop
this ancient threat to modern day some
of the sets and costumes actually look
pretty good in this episode I think the
main problem here is the acting right
from the first word of narration I could
tell what we were in for the pyramid is
like this dark underground maze
the secret passages and dead ends it's
pretty spooky but I'm not afraid this is
also my favorite scream ever now then we
have the lady who says she's a reporter
but it's actually Francis Neela your
sister silence foolish peasant summoner
is mine like I mentioned the sets
costumes and even effects look pretty
decent for a goosebumps episode so there
is stuff to like about this one
but those actors and the characters they
were playing just brought return of the
mummy way down for me and to number four
number four say cheese and die again
from season three say cheese and die was
one of the honorable mentions from my
best list pretty big drop off for the
sequel Greg banks is given the
assignment of writing a true story that
changed his life for a class in school
when he writes about his experience with
the evil camera that predicted the
future and made it bad with every photo
taken his teacher doesn't believe the
story and flunks him the only way Greg
can reverse his failing grade is to
prove to his teacher that the camera
exists
Greg reluctantly looks for and find the
sinister camera but it ends up being
much more trouble than it's worth as he
discovers its powers have ballooned to
massive proportions Ryan Gosling starred
as Greg in the original say cheese and I
would have been interesting to see him
try and tackle this sequel you know the
famous thing from the Jason movies well
they do that here but it's
aagghhh very cute so you'd think the
characters from the last episode about
this camera would have learned their
lesson to not be so reckless with it
wrong
are you nuts broken money taking your
picture that girls at Jase one minute
she's adamant that Gregg take the camera
back to where it came from and the next
she's all willy-nilly with it and
doesn't even care the fools the worst
thing about this episode is the
ridiculous and inexcusably bad fat
effect they put on this kid that's right
his doomed fate is to live life as a fat
guy making the big kids out there feel
really good aren't you goosebumps anyway
I laugh out loud every time I see this
part they put cotton balls in his cheeks
and stretch out his face and post from
then on and it's horrendous until he
turns into fat bastard from Austin
Powers yeah in my belly it's not a joke
you have to help us at least the d-bag
teacher got what was coming to him at
the end of the episode
that's that's quite amusing
[Music]
number three strained peas from season
three this episode's villain is an evil
baby terrifying when Nick's parents come
home with his new baby sister grace he
can tell right away that something is
wrong the baby seems like it's out to
get him and even talks Nick's parents
don't believe him and as little grace
makes messes no baby should be capable
of Nick gets the blame he desperately
sets out to prove that grace is not his
little sister as the baby displays more
and more monstrous behavior once again
the villain is a baby the episode isn't
scary it would fail at being scary to a
three-year-old
I know they're trying to play up and
exaggerate the fear that older siblings
have when they get younger brothers or
sisters that they won't get any
attention from their parents that tropes
been used in every kid's program from
the beginning of time but this twist on
it is terrible
grace ends up being the actual offspring
of monsters as there was a mixup at the
hospital oh and when they get their
actual baby it talks to number two you
can't scare me from season two I'd
hesitate to even call this an episode
there's no structure and it feels
unfinished Courtney is a fearless and
perfect student who is constantly
pranked by two boys whose goal is to
finally scare her there repeatedly
unsuccessful as she outsmarts them at
every turn their last-ditch effort is to
lead her to a swap where a mud monster
supposedly lives one of them dresses as
the monster but they all get more than
they bargained for when they discover
that the mud monster legend is real this
one just freaking sucks there's no
lesson there's no payoff there's no
twist it's just 20 something minutes of
these boys trying to scare this girl she
doesn't get scared and it ends that's it
in the climax when they see that the mud
monster is real you'd think one of two
things would happen either Courtney does
get scared and is proven wrong about the
mud monster
existing or she ends up being a part of
the mud monster somehow that's why she's
not scared of anything because she's a
monster instead of those logical
conclusions she just talks to the
monster don't interrupt
I can feel it I can feel your anger is
she the Emperor what the hell is that
she goes on talking until the mud
monster dries out and seems dead then I
guess the twist happened when it comes
back to life after it starts raining
again to scare the boys pointless just a
pointless waste of a goosebumps episode
as bad as this is there is one worse
and the number one worst goosebumps
episode is go eat worms from season two
worms are gross right right Todd is a
mean kid who loves worms and often
pranks his little sister with them when
the worm starts showing up in his lunch
and even his bed he thinks his sister is
getting him back for pranking her but
finds out something much stranger is
going on this is just a gross out
episode it's actually really really lazy
Todd is a puke of a kid he deserves what
he gets but it's not pulled off in an
interesting way and he doesn't learn
anything this kid even rubs his face in
worms at one point
yeah no one sleeps like that I will say
those worms are better actors than
Todd's mom if you were my client I tell
you to plead insanity crazy about worm I
just think they're cool that's all try
me
the prosecution rests you get it because
she's a lawyer after being attacked by a
giant worm Todd stops being interested
in them and moves on to fish the ending
twist here is also terrible
[Music]
what
so that's the worst don't get me wrong
these episodes aren't all that memorable
and definitely don't overshadow how good
this show could be when it was at its
best
like any anthology series some stories
are going to be really clever
interesting and in this case scary while
others are gonna be about worms spooky
worms I want to hear what you guys think
what is your least favorite episode of
goosebumps what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know for more content subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome Walter like my Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter B and
follow along on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future that's for next week I just
have one question for you
[Music]
[Applause]
you